polémique autour d'une innovation lancé
par google le moteur de recherche
américain sur internet pour se
distinguer de ses concurrents la firme
californienne a lancé un logiciel qui
permet de visualiser n'importe quel
endroit du monde
une intention ludique et commerciale dès
qu'il commence à faire peur certaines
images de sites stratégiques pourrait
être détournée à des fins terroristes
patrice veulent et benoît fév les frais
d'un cap
voici la centrale nucléaire de luca ceds
en australie dès qu'il a découvert cette
image sur le site google earth
l'un des responsables du programme
nucléaire australien a demandé qu on la
retire immédiatement
invoquant de possibles problèmes avec
des terroristes
car aujourd'hui sur certains sites
internet on peut voir ce qu avant on
nous cachait voici par exemple la tour
eiffel d'un côté c'est une image bien
innocente
de l'autre elle est si précise qu'elle
pourrait servir à quelques personnes
malintentionnées pour préparer un
attentat
que ce soit le palais de l'elysée
l'aéroport de roissy charles de gaulle
le centre de londres la place saint
pierre à rome le siège de la cia à
langley ou la maison blanche à
washington
plus personne n'est à l'abri toutes ces
images sont maintenant dans le domaine
public et cette situation inquiète les
experts
ya des dangers éventuellement mais le
problème c'est que l'imagerie n'est pas
la seule source d'information donc
certes on pourra récupérer une image on
pourra avoir des un certain nombre
d'informations
mais ce sera forcément suffisant des
dizaines de satellites ses visées
militaires surveillent chaque seconde
notre planète
pour le moment les images les plus
précises ne sont pas disponibles
elles sont soigneusement gardés par les
services secrets des pays concernés
mais pour combien de temps qui aurait
pensé que cette image parfaite de la
centrale du bugey dans l'ain serait un
jour disponible sur internet et que sur
ce cliché de la place rouge à moscou
on pourrait compter les voitures garées
sur le parking
expliqué